[MUSIC]
Hello, my name is Nev Pierce. I'm Editor-At-Large for Empire
Magazine and I'm here to say as little as possible and
let this man do all the talking. Before you got into writing
professionally, there's this little period of time where
you worked on political campaigns, is that correct? How
did you get involved in that? It's not a clear trajectory.
Like I did this, then I worked in politics, then I did this.
So, in the midst around that time, I was writing that first
play my best friend a guy named Jay Carson, he's the
character Steve in Ides of March, and Farragut
North is based on him. He was having this meteoric rise
that already began in college and he said 'I'm working on
the Senate campaign. Why don't you come work on it?' And
I did, and I had a blast. It was an amazing experience.
We were all over the state, you know, a couple twenty-year-
old guys feeling like, in our own infinite small way, we
were we were going to make a difference and make history,
and we won that race. And it was amazing. I mean, there's
very few things in life where, you know, on a particular
day at a particular time, whether you have succeeded or
failed and in an election is one of those things. And it's,
as I learned at that time, such a rush, such a high, when
you win. And as I learned later, so crushing when you lose.
It's very black and white, but we won and I wanted more,
and that led to Hillary Clinton's Senate race in 2000, Bill
Bradley's presidential in 2000, and ultimately Howard Dean's
presidential in 2004, which is the last campaign I've ever
worked on, I guess over ten years ago now. And I drew from
all those experiences to write Farragut and  continue
to draw on them to write House of Cards, but politics was
never lik a 'thing' for me. I'm not a political junkie.
I've written 12 plays and only one of them has to do
with politics. And, you know, the reason you guys probably
showed up is because of House of Cards and so, the two
things that I'm most known for, Farragut North and Ides
of March on the one hand and House of Cards in the other
both are in the world of politics, but that's
not a subject that interests me. Power. No, I'm
not trying to be cavalier here. Power really interests me.
Politics is a subset of power and politics in Washington
at this level, you're seeing power explored in the most
sophisticated way with the highest stakes,
but I'm just as interested in fascinated by the power relationship,
within the marriage between Frank and Claire Underwood,
which is the real subject of the show, not politics, if
that makes sense. So, can we talk a little bit about how
how closely Farragut was to your own experience or your
friends' experience, but also then the experience of seeing that
staged and then I can't imagine what it's like to get a
phone call from George Clooney, or Clooney's people
saying, 'Hey, we think you've got something here. We'd like
to make a film.' The most that I've ever had
with that play is a staged reading before I got the call
from Warner Brothers that they want to turn into a movie.
It had never been on stage. In fact, I'd sent it to forty
theatres around the country. I didn't have an agent at
the time, and those that got back to me rejected it and
most didn't even get back to me. So, I put that play away
and I began working on subsequent plays and when I got
the call, it was because, you know I won't go into all the
details. After I wrote that play, I managed to get an agent
and that agent read my work and said, 'I want to send this
play out.' I said 'Good luck. I've sent it everywhere' but
he sent out. He immediately got some interest from
Broadway Theatre producers, which was crazy because I've never
had a single production of anything. But based on that,
my agent felt encouraged enough to send it out
to Hollywood just as a writing sample in the
hopes that I might get some meetings and maybe get like
a staffing job on a TV show or something, but somehow in
the way that these things happen in their magical way,
it ended up at a junior executive desk at Warner Brothers,
who read it, and he's about my age, you He only gave it to his
boss, a guy named Kevin McCormick who was an executive
at Warner Bros for many years and a brilliant guy and he
had a discretionary fund. So, he could just put something
in development without having to go to anyone else. And
we got a call saying, 'we'd like to turn this play into a
movie and George Clooney, and Leo DiCaprio want to produce.'
Remember, I'd never had a production of a play. I
was temping at a place in Rockefeller Plaza where my job
was to staple things and put them in the mail. And I said,
let me think about it. I'll get back to you next week.
No, I sh[__] myself. And then, when I cleaned that up,
I went out to LA and I met with George's
people and eventually George and Leo, nd the Warner
Brothers' folks, and it was happening, you know, so rewiring
brain to that, which was totally new for me, was hard,
but also thrilling. And I did a few drafts and then I turned
it over to George Clooney and Grant Heslov, and they worked
off those drafts and did their drafts and at the point
I handed it off, my work was done. It was very much at
that point going to be George's film. I mean, he was directing
it. He was in it. He had pulled together the cast, which
was an amazing cast, and he had found the financing and
he had wrested it away from Warner Brothers to get it distributed
by Sony, which never - it's very difficult to wrest
a property away from one studio for it to go to another. So,
it's very much his thing and and they did their work and
they changed a lot, and a lot of the screenplay for
that film is them and I was fine with that because
I knew they understood the core of the story and they didn't
want to mess with that. And that was this young man, at
this fork in the road, having this great sort of ethical
choice before him and he chooses one direction and another.
And in the moment, he chooses this direction, as the moment.
He becomes a monster and it's that moment of becoming a
monster which I wanted to arrive at and that is what they
achieved, I think in the film, in a way that was very different
from the play. And they got beautiful performances out
of everyone and I'm very proud of the work
that we all did, but particularly grateful to George for
being so passionate about it, making it happen because
those sort of films. I mean, look around, they're not
getting made anymore. Certainly, well, at least not in
America, as much. If you don't have a comic book hero, good
luck, you know, and so I mean all in all for me, it
was incredibly positive experience and it opened up. It
opened up that door that I got my pinky toe into and
you know, there's no doubt in my mind that I wouldn't
be sitting here if it wasn't for a number of people, Kevin
McCormick, the junior exec that worked for him. George Clooney,
Grant Heslov, all the actors that said yes to that film,
the people that put the money into it. If it weren't for
all of those people taking a chance on this piece of material
by someone who had no credits whatsoever, then
I'd still be stapling stuff and mailing it. So. you have
Farragut North and you get the call about doing the movie,
but then you get BAFTA and Oscar nominated and
then a call about House of Cards. You've written for stage,
you've then written for the big screen. Was there any hesitancy
then by going, 'Well now  I've got to learn how to write for television.'
And is that much of a different experience? Yeah. Again,
it's a little messy because it's not that linear. The way
I'd gotten that agent which is how Ides of March happened
is by writing a pilot for AMC. AMC's the network that
did Mad Men and Breaking Bad and Walking Dead. But when
I got the gig, they were just starting and a good friend
of mine, Sam Foreman, had a really good meeting with
them. He had an agent. He had shows produced
on the stage and they had said to him, 'We love your spec
script. We're looking for three things, as we start this
new venture of original content. We're looking for period
pieces, espionage pieces or smart horror and do you have
any of those things?' And Sam said, 'I do not' and they said,
come back when you do and he said 'okay' and then Sam and
I went for a drink and he said, 'do you have any ideas for
period espionage or smart horror?' And I said, 'what the
f[__] is smart horror?' He's like, 'I have no idea'. I guess
it's the Walking Dead, right? But we're like, okay,
we don't know what smart horror is. So, our best
bet here is espionage period and then there was a few
screenplays that I wrote. One was a blind script for
Warner Brothers that was part of the Ides of March deal.
I hubristically try to tackle Tale of Two Cities. I was like
the sixth writer and twenty years to try to make that happen
for Warner Brothers and I think I wrote a good script and
I think the five scripts before me were also really good.
They just couldn't commit. And then I wrote a couple
other screenplays that didn't get made, and
I was sort of at this moment where I go, 'well, I had this
movie that George Clooney made, and got nominated for
the stuff. And I got my foot in the door. And now, I've
had three scripts that haven't gotten made. It
may be ending.' I mean, you know that you can only write
so many scripts that don't get made before people stop
hiring you to write scripts and it was right at that moment
that Fincher called and said, 'have you heard of this thing called
House of Cards? They want to make a TV show'. I'd heard
of it because if you write anything about politics at some
point, someone's going to say, 'Did you watch House of Cards?'
And at that time they meant just the BBC version, ours didn't
exist. So I've been meaning to watch it anyway, and I figured
well Fincher is one of the great living filmmakers and
within ten seconds you realize when you're talking
David Fincher, that you're dealing with the sort of mind
that you may never encounter again. I mean, he has a savate-
like knowledge of the craft in the history of filmmaking.
He is incredibly clever, and witty, but also concise and
deep and blunt and profound in his thinking about art.
His synapses fire faster than just about anyone
I know and I just felt through the phone, like I was dealing
with this life force that I wanted to tap into. I wanted to
hold onto and work with, and be around and we started
talking about House of Cards. And we had similar
instincts on the approach to it, and we were starting to
come up with new ideas on the fly. And it just became clear
that I had to do this. We're going to open to questions
from the audience in a couple of minutes. I just wanted
to ask, I'll be quick. That's good. I mean I shouldn't
have prepared so much. I could have gone to the pub. Structure.
so you have the structure of a play, you have the structure of a film.
How does a structure differ when you're doing television
or does it differ that much given that it's not really TV,
everything's dropping the same
time. Yeah. Well for me TV's a lot
closer to the theatre because there's an ongoing dialogue
with the actors and the department heads.
It's like you have this crew and this family that you're
spending a lot of time with, and just discovering things with
as you would in the rehearsal process for a play. And something
that you discover in say episode 2, even though you've
planned out the whole season, might influence scripts to come
and have this ripple effect. And so there's a lot more
dialogue between the collaborators going back and forth.
Then I think you have on a film, where most the time you
have the script and then the director takes it and directs
it. There's also the fact that you have just one season
for us, thirteen hours. A film is much more like a short
story, or a poem, not a moment or line that can
be wasted. It has to resolve itself in 90 to 120
minutes. And with a television show, it doesn't. I mean,
each hour chapter, whatever you want to call it, is a discrete
thing that has its own beginning, middle, and an end to
a degree, but it doesn't have to completely resolve itself.
I mean, it could actually end in a place of total lack
of resolution, but the feeling you're heading somewhere,
so you can really take your time with the storytelling,
I think dive into character in ways that are impossible
to do in film, or even a stage play. Because you have the
hours to do it. In that way, I think it's closest to a novel
more than anything else, which is also how people are watching
it to these days. They're sort of picking it up and putting
it down when they want to, and choosing how many
chapters they want to read. And you have no control over
that, the same with a novelist doesn't have any control
over, whether you read their novel on the train
or in your living room, in one sitting or over the course
of many months. So, you know, the approach that Fincher
wanted to take and I guess I didn't know
any better. I mean none of us have made TV. We didn't
really know what we're doing, but we just figured, okay,
we'll make a film that just happens to be thirteen hours long.
And I can't describe to you what that means other than,
that's what we tried to do. And I think that's what a season
is, for us. So, we don't really think about episodes as much
as we think about the film, and we just have a lot
longer film, and more time to play with than the typical film.
So if we have a couple of roving mics, so if you have a
question, can you stick your hand in the air? Let's start
over here. In House of Cards season 1, and I think every
episode eight or nine, Francis offers Doug to teach him
how to play chess. My question is, would Doug have faired much better,
if you taken up that offer? or sort of more generally
speaking, how far is chess maybe an organizing principle
to the entire show? I believe when Francis offered
to teach Stamper how to play chess, Claire had disappeared
off to New York to be with Adam Galloway, and he was feeling
sort of in this restless purgatory and Stamper, if anything
is functional, it's about control. It's about getting
things done in a very practical way and he wasn't, certainly
not in season one, equipped, to deal with the emotional
limbo that his boss was in. So better to just get away.
I've never thought about it in terms of would he
have fared better, if he had learned how to play chess.
I don't know. Maybe, I mean, chess is, and this bleeds into
your second question I guess, chess to me is
fascinating. I wrote a play about Garry Kasparov
match against Deep Blue in 1997. And I'm not
even an amateur chess player. I mean, I can hold my own
with the average player out there, but it's vast.
I read that there were more possible
games of chess than there are particles in the universe
and when studying someone like a Garry Kasparov, it was
actually someone I brought up a lot my early conversations.
with Fincher. What's interesting about Kasparov
in the reason he's one of the greatest players of all
time is not because of his strategy or tactics. It's not
that he's thinking 15 moves ahead. It's that he's creating
chaos on the board. He will sacrifice two pieces for seemingly
no reason whatsoever, with not necessarily a concrete plan
on how to get back that capital. But he knows that the
person on the other side of the table's saying, 'why did he
just do that? He must have some grand plan. He must be
thinking 15 moves ahead'. And at that level with Grandmasters
it's about, it's like tennis, who makes the first mistake.
So if I know I'm willingly making this mistake, but what
I get back is I'm psychologically throwing off the other
guy who will make a bigger mistake than it, then it's worth
it. And that's something we we use all the time with Frank
Underwood. To steal one of the lines from
the show, 'if you don't like the way the table is set,
turn over the table' and something that Fincher and I talked
a lot about was that politics is it's not a
symphony. It's jazz. It is call and response. It is reaction.
The great politicians might plan out 15 steps ahead, but
they'll get to step 2 and everything changes. There's some
crisis, there's some unexpected thing. There is the chaos of
the world. And at that moment, you have to get rid of the
next 13 steps and you have to react to that and develop
a new plan that will the next day probably be
thrown out the window because of new chaos introducing itself.
And it's how do you manage that chaos and make it work for
you. How do you play jazz with it? That really makes the
great politicians great. And then the very best politicians
know how to create chaos and make it work for them. So
yeah, I mean, I guess in that respect. Yeah, I'm not thinking
about chess all the time as I write House of Cards, but
there's certainly plenty of parallels to be drawn.
Does that metaphor hold true for the process of actually
writing the show as well? You may be thinking
oh this is going to happen in episode 13'. Oh, yeah all the time.
Totally. I mean from from creative discoveries
to things that are simply out of our control, creative
discoveries might be something like in season 1. Peter
Russo's character was a big character, but never intended
to be the guy who ran for governor, that was a whole other
character, but Corey Stoll was so great, and when we saw
him on screen with Kevin, we all felt just, we want to see
more of that. I mean that's lightning in a bottle that
we've caught that you don't want to let that lightning go.
So I made a huge shift in the middle of filming the season
where I took this other character story who was running
for governor, and I gave it to Peter Russo. Now, that's
not just about changing whose name is above the dialogue.
That required page one rewrites from episode five onwards,
but it was in response to this discovery we had made and
it was totally worth it because It actually made Peter
Russo story stronger. It consolidated the story for the
season. So, we were really focusing on this one guy as opposed
to two. And you know, it worked for us. There are other
instances where you know, you might lose an actor. I mean,
in the States, you can have series regular deals, and forgive
me for being a little jargony here, but a series regular deal
means that basically you own the actor. You have them
in first position. They can't do anything else unless they
get permission from you. But there's a lot of characters
that you don't have in first position because you can't
afford it. So they might be in a fair number of
episodes and you kind of count on their existence, but
they get some big offer from another thing and boom, they're
gone, and then you built the story around this person that
is no longer available to you. You have no choice but to
change your story and react to it. So I'm not going to
name names, but I mean, that is happened before for us.
And, you know, look here's a tiny one, it wasn't global but,
you know, you guys remember in season 1, episode 9, I think
where Francis says 'I despise children. There. I said
it' and in the beginning of that episode, he's talking about
stuff with Peter Russo. Russo's kids are running around.
One of Russo's kids knocks some coffee. It burns his hand and
he said, 'I despise children. There. I said it' and then the
rest of the episode you see him wearing a bandage. Well,
Kevin had actually injured his hand and there was this
bandage there and we didn't want to deal with having to
shoot everything where we are hiding this hand, so I created
that opening to the show so that we could justify him wearing
a bandage. But then I'm like, well, I might as well make
the most of it. Let's have him say he despises children.
Yeah. It's one of my favorite direct addresses, but that's
just the chaos of the world, you know.
Firstly about the Ides of March, which is a film I love
very much and fortunately saw it in New York and it was
a really fantastic experience for us when it came out. You
touched slightly on your research, which obviously
for that came from your experience. So firstly, what tools
do you use for researching for other things, other
projects? And the other aspect is about the male and the
female voice within your work as a writer. So, within me,
Ides of March, even though it was quite a male heavy film,
you had very strong female voices, and this is also existent
within House of Cards. How do you as a male writer write
so well for women? Well, thank you for liking Ides of March
and for the compliment you paid me at the end, writing
well for women, I mean, I'll start with the second part
first, which is that it's not just me writing well for
women, it's also the women I employ on my writing staff,
you know, which is an important thing to do. If you're
going to have female characters in your show that said
I don't, I really am against the notion that the female
writers should write the female characters and the male writers
should write the male characters. I mean, what is writing,
if not the attempt to put yourself in other people's shoes?
so, I expect my female writers to be able to write men
well to the best of their ability and vice versa. Now,
we are all limited by our own experiences. There are certain
things, I will never be able to access because of things
that are genetic, things that are in my upbringing, things
that are cultural. We all have our limited horizons and
often our unconscious biases, but I think writing is an
attempt to acknowledge those and sometimes get beyond
them and find the universal in all of our experiences.
So, the way we approach writing men and women on House
of Cards: it's paradoxical; On the one hand, we want to
be gender blind. I mean, all the characters
are equally intelligent and venal. Balzac is
one of my favorite writers because the women in his stories
are just as insidious as everyone else, and I think that
we're looking for the strength and also the weakness
in every character and there's a term that
is, I don't know if it's used here often, but certainly
in the States, like 'strong female characters'. I take a
little bit of issue with 'strong female characters', as though,
you know, why do you have to put the word strong front
of it? There are strong male characters
and weak male characters. There are strong female characters.
and weak female characters. There are strong and weak
trans characters. You can kind of look at a spectrum and
on one end of the spectrum is misogyny and neglect. Misogyny,
we all know what that means, but there's a sort of indirect
form of misogyny, which is like the absence of female characters
or  substantial storylines for them, or that they're
just relegated to their body or just to their relationship
to a man, right? So that's one end of the spectrum and
that's bad. The other end of the spectrum is trying to
place women on some sort of pedestal, you know, trying
to make them these sort of goddesses or fantasies and
almost trying too hard to make them strong, you know,
which is another way. I actually am neglecting the
complexity of their lives. So, if you avoid those two ends
and just say, well, we're just going to say this character,
man or woman has a need. What is that thing that they need
in order willing to do to to get that need?
Then you can begin to address gender in a sophisticated
way. Obviously, there are certain things that are different
in the human experience between men and women. If Frank
Underwood were having perimenopausal hot flashes, that
would be strange. Like that's not an experience a guy's going
to have. It is an experience that women can and will have.
So, we told that story for Claire in part in season 1.
But here's the big thing: that wasn't her story. That
was part of her life. But if we had said, this is her
story and her story is only one that is relegated to something
that's gender-specific, then we would have been reductive
with her. But if we're just telling the story of Claire
Underwood and it so happens because she's this age, that
this is something she's going through, then we're just
being realistic. So, I don't know if that answers your
question, but that's that's how we try to approach it.
And then the first part of your question, research.
For House of Cards, it's a mixture of book learning
of experts, Jay Carson, the guy I talked about earlier is
our political consultant. If he doesn't know something,
he puts us in touch with people that are. It's my own personal
experience, and it's also my writers' own personal experience
And oftentimes, the research is not so much political.
It's drawing from, you know, you could see something happen
on its sidewalk, like a man screaming. You know, a homeless
man screaming on a sidewalk, that's research. If you absorb
it, if it means something to you, if you find yourself
using it and colliding it with your character, you know.
So, I think it's about being open on other subject matter
like Garry Kasparov. I mean saying, same thing,
I mean, it's really project-specific, but you know,
the adage 'write what you know' is a very wise
one but also it's important to write what you don't know,
if only to discover the things that you know that you didn't
know. Cheers. Hello, finally, gotten more. I got into NYU
Tisch earlier this year to do a masters in screenwriting.
But the same time I got an agent and two of my script got picked
up, and I'm developing one of them now, which is a sitcom,
which is kind of a weird experience. I don't really know what
I'm doing, but I'm just asking you, is there any advice
you can give for the next steps that I'm in? Because it's
all based around uncertainty and I've really no idea apart
from the ideas I have in my head about what I'm creating.
Yeah. Is there any advice? The only real advice I could
give is to do the work. I mean, you know, I always struggle
when writers ask for advice because, you know, there's
no formula. I mean, congrats on getting an agent and congrats
on NYU. It's a great school. And I mean, it sounds like
you're creating the opportunities for yourself
that are beginning to pay off. And, you know, a big
part of any form of success in any industry is looking
for opportunities. And then making opportunities, if they're
not being laid at your feet, and that can be school. It
could be going out and making your own film on your own.
It can be, you know, if no one is doing any of your pilots,
writing a play and doing that with your friends. No one
can stop you from that. There's a million ways to create
opportunities for yourself. But ultimately, all of that
is only there if you've got the pages. The only thing
you can do that is completely in your control and it ultimately
will make you successful, at least financially or whatever,
as a form of success, although the real success has nothing
to do with that but it's having the pages and putting in
the time and the thousands of hours and thousands of pages
you must write. I don't think that talking about what you're
writing counts. I don't think thinking about what you
want to write counts. I think the only thing that counts
is the actual writing. So, you know, if you've got a sitcom
that's getting some traction, you know, there's a lot of
strategic things that you know, if we sat down for an hour
and talked about what this agent is doing this and
going to this studio, there's all that bulls[__],
that’s strategerly. But no matter what happens,
you're either going to be making your show in which case
it's not about buying a new car and you know, going into all
the clubs. It's about you've got to put your shoulder to the
wheel even more or you're not going to make your show
in which case, the only thing that you can do is write
the next one and then write the next one. And then write
the next one. And then write the next one. And the next
one, and the next one, and the next one and never stop
until you die.
I will die, right? Which sounds morbid, but it's
not to me. It's completely liberating because it can't
get worse from there. Like, you have that thought, and
you go, okay. Let's get to work, you know, so that's a
piece of advice to just remember that every day, when you
wake up, puts things in perspective. That seems like a
wonderful moment on which to end our evening. Thank you
so much for coming because all that mattered was the story.
Nothing else, not your ego, not your training, not your
ambitions. This story is all I care about, you know, we're
in this production office in Dublin, and I went upstairs
and I borrowed somebody's computer. And I wrote the scene
in probably 30 minutes.
[END]